this is like the first stage you know
there's a problem and and and there is
it's a real problem let's say you're not
imagining yeah
some pain there is a pain now the
question is how you build the vision
around it before you put together the
team you need to do a vision that will
lead to a strategy and for many
executive in product management
sometimes it's easy to shoot out
features
but they're not connected to a vision
so you see many product managers
struggling to find a vision around that
problem so the problem can be solved in
a you know in some kind of a hack or you
can solve it all together with a more
holistic
and more exhaustive solution that will
take care of the entire
pain welcome to 20 minute leaders just
sit back relax and learn from the
leaders of today it's a journey each one
is different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serona partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders today meet omer efrat
vice president of product at torque
omar is a seasoned product leader with
10 plus years track record in delivering
successful world-class products
he is an alum of kellogg school of
management and an elite military tech
unit he is currently the vice president
of product at torque a groundbreaking
cyber security startup
formerly the head of product at
appsplier and vice president of product
at fiber today digital turbine
omer entered product management after
seven years as a software engineer
omega fat welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for joining me today
happy to be here thank you
thank you i'm really excited to talk
about product and product development
had you know incredible a career with
product besides you know being at the at
the open university and and doing your
mba at northwestern at the college
school of management and being in the
cyber defense sector and then
transitioning to uh being an
entrepreneur a head of product at sungle
media vp product at fiber then head of
product at appsfire and now most
recently a vp product at torque
looking at no code solutions for
security teams which is obviously you
know a crazy market right now with with
everything that's happening and from
what i believe is just the beginning of
what we're going to see a real
revolution there so so lots of
experiences oma and you know these 20
minutes i want to understand from your
perspective what does it mean to build
great products and you know be being an
executive product manager and leading
teams of product managers what is that
like and and how should we go about
thinking through this so omel tell me a
little bit about yourself and then we'll
dive into products perfect so you kind
of summarize it
kind of like efficiently and
i've been
doing product management i think over 10
years now
and i began as
again i began as a software engineer a
software team lead
still in one of the tech units
very familiar story
and i pivoted to product when i was an
entrepreneur
in
the company me and a couple of
other colleagues started
again very interesting startups won't go
into details now but
there
i had one of my partners were kind of
took the role of the cto so i had to
step back from the engineering role and
move to the business side and i think
this is where i had to
become a product manager very quickly
very aggressively
and
i was like my job was to find exactly
how we're gonna meet that market need
how we're gonna actually execute that
um and this is again 2010 when i
actually
moved to the product side of the
business
um right i think so
transitioning to the product side walk
me you know take me back to that moment
where you're now shifting your mindset
you know engineering you know management
business and now product what was that
change in mindset for you like
it was instead of thinking of
how we're going to solve the problem and
to like change my perspective of are we
solving the right problem or which
problem should we solve
or actually defining
the pain of the customer which was not
easy
right
and so defining the pain of the customer
let's start there
you know if you're looking at across
your career the different experiences
what have you learned about identifying
pains of customers and and how to do
that either well or or not so well
um so again just just a disclaimer and
my entire career i was working in b2b
companies business business i was
my entire experience and perspective
is
serving
other organizations so when i'm talking
about the customer pain it's usually
some kind of a business partner pain
and
so i learned that it's
kind of still difficult to imagine the
exact problem of your customer without
feeling it yourself this is something
that again there's a lot of literature
about it
but it's
very difficult to sit and build a
solution
as they call it in the basement or you
know in your own labs
without being outside in the field
which is the main challenge when you're
trying to build a new product
so perhaps some a tangible example of
you know where
you know how we know being out there
and with with one of the companies that
you were with where did that translate
into a positive experiences and
identifying the pain point that then
translated into a good product
again many many
expert product managers said it before
me but you really need to put yourself
in the shoes of your customers
it's
i can give some of the examples that we
had in apps flyer maybe it was a very
recent experience
we were trying to build something
quite different than the experience we
had in in the company back then it's
some kind of a predictive engine and the
goal was to understand exactly
how the media buyer or the user
acquisition managers
are
facing the challenge of understanding
how to manage their campaigns again
upside is not the campaign management
companies so we didn't have that
knowledge so we really needed to reach
out
to a very specific personas in in the in
our customers organizations and
look very deeply to understand how the
process looks like where exactly the
they're having that pain point that
make them make the work inefficient or
or frustrating
do you do that simply through sitting
with them and talking to them through
iterating over
you know pocs how do you actually get
into their into their minds
great question that that's that's the
actual challenge eventually um right
so so one of the ways again this is a
bit extreme example maybe but one of the
ways um
i personally experienced those those
pains in this for this example was a
couple of years ago when i actually had
to sit in the
to sit in the seat of the user
acquisition manager
for some of those same clients
so i think when i when i actually
experience it myself
when i saw exactly what kind of
challenges what kind of frustrations
you're facing
when i said again
let's say two years later when i said
again with the same type of users with
the same user acquisition managers of
many other big organizations
i can even when i ask them the questions
i could ask those questions from a very
let's call it um
knowledgeable
position because i knew their pain i
wasn't that just asking general
questions i knew what they're facing so
i'm just asking directly
i know that you have that in that pain
tell me more about it and then they
could actually open up very quickly and
share very deep insights about how they
are trying to manage their business
today and
what are their things
right so so once you get you know into
their minds and you understand the pain
point of your you got to solve
especially being in an executive
position with product managers how how
do you then structure your organization
so that you can actually be agile with
the product and develop the right one
what how what have you experienced that
you know helped you manage the process
in the most efficient way
great so
so let's say that you you got the
problem right this is like the first
stage you know there's a problem and and
and there is it's a real problem let's
say you're not imagining yeah
some pain there is a pain now the
question is how you build the vision
around it before you put together the
team you need to do a vision that will
lead to a strategy and for many
executive in product management
sometimes it's easy to shoot out
features
but they're not connected to a vision
so you see many product managers
struggling to find a vision around that
problem so the problem can be solved in
a you know in some kind of a hack or you
can solve it all together with a more
holistic
and more exhaustive solution that will
take care of the entire pain
and this is i think in my three last
roles was the main challenge to okay we
saw the problem we see
we can allocate we see exactly what
hurts them we know the problem is we
know how much money is behind that
problem but now we need to put together
a vision
that will solve it all together
which sometimes organizational
organization wise can be challenging
because not everyone in organization are
happy to follow
you know to put huge amounts of budgets
on like setting up new visions
but that's right and so obviously you
know
but but so you're coming with a product
understanding and you're understanding
the pain point and then you're coming to
an organization that has r d it has
business it has sales and marketing and
you basically have to to sell everybody
on the conviction that you've had by
understanding the pain point right
yes
and you need to show you need to show
the paper you need to show the
the size of the problem which means the
size of the opportunity of how much
you know this is not just
two clients problem or too small for one
by the way this is
very common mistake that people find a
very good problem but it's not big
enough
so they're solving a small problem which
is fine
but it's not good for if you want to
build a huge product or a huge company
around it
again not saying it from a critic
perspective but you know sometimes you
know you need to solve a specific niche
feel and it's good that you solve it
but in some cases like companies that
want to get to the next stage or let's
say the past unicorn stage you need to
think of
no this is what we're dealing with in
this industry we're looking for the past
unicorn you need to solve really big
problems
so you're looking for a problem you're
looking to to prove that it's very big
and if you prove that it's very big and
it's very clear from here convincing
everyone or creating
successful campaigns within the company
it's much easier assuming you have the
it almost sounds like it's a yeah
it almost sounds like it's pretty
similar to an entrepreneur that's coming
to a vc to pitch on on you know getting
funding it's the same thing you're
asking the company to fund you with time
resources personnel
and and cognitive
and cognitive allocation and so on once
you've done that we found the pain point
we've convinced the organization about
our vision and we're ready to execute
where are we at now
so now we need to get the organization
or the product org
that is connected to an engineering org
you need both and of course you need
sales and the other parts that let's
assume they're already in place
so in this case we need to um
think or there's maybe i'll give an
anecdote for
something that is changing today
and
of course and the question is how many
product managers do you need
is for a certain project or a certain
product or a certain company
and
in the past in the past in israel at
least again my experience from israeli
companies around you know the past 50
years
um
product management use grew in israel
for more a technical side or you had rnd
organizations and then product came
around
and when they came they were like kind
of wrapping the engineering thing so
there was a very common
um
thumb law to use of like how many
product managers you need how many
engineers so do you think used to say
like in the past okay you need a pm for
every six engineers you need a pm for
every eight engineers and this is how
you decided how big your product team
will be
but today we see a complete different
trend it's happening today at talk i
think it happened also in apps fire and
it's happening in many other startups
that i'm in touch with that
the
amount of pm is
derived from the size of the problem you
need to solve
let's say that today talk i'm trying to
solve a problem that's we defined it as
one problem but it has many different
sub
problems to solve and each one of those
sub problems requires someone to to
really look deep
and research and investigate and think
exactly how you define how you cut it
narrow enough in order to give it a
great execution
so the number of pms today is equivalent
to the numbers of issues i'm trying to
solve
so even if you have a team of 20
engineers
sometimes you still need 8 pms or 7 pms
which 10 years ago would sound absurd
but today it's it's something we see in
many startups around us
now what do those pms do in the life
cycle of this product so now that we
have the vision
and we're about to execute and we have
the resources you know once the
engineering teams are running
and they're and they're and they're
working on the product what do the pms
do at that point i've always been
curious what does the pm of the product
do you know once the engineer says okay
got it i understand i'm starting the
sprint i'll talk to you in two weeks
yeah so that's a great question some of
them still ask that it's okay i'm joking
they know what they're doing so
maybe and and i essence from another
perspective of you know the difference
between different types of pms that used
to be common in the industry so in the
past couple of years they used to have
technical pms which would call the
inbound pms that mostly work with the
team with the engineering team and you
have the outbound pms that would be
more out facing and talking more to
customers and doing more support and
whatever what's not with the market so
today there's a trend that i'm really
standing um i'm trying to to go with
that trend because i really believe in
it of using what i call full stack
product managers which means that at pm
you need to be inbound and output at the
same time
i mean together not necessarily at the
same moment but they need to have the
expertise of
going down technically with the
engineering team we needed but also join
the sales call and steal the show when
needed
and i expect yeah the same
person
to do
both things in a very high grade again
some of them need to you know if someone
is coming from the engineering side they
need to learn more to become a better
outbound product but
i the way i see the growth and and what
i'm looking today and in candidates is
that combination now because we did it
like um vertically because now the full
stock pms i can break down the product
to many features that each feature has
their own market research and their own
execution and their own plan
and that's feature is being managed that
sub product is being managed by a single
person
that is the owner of that capability
from now and forever
so this is just like how first we will
divide the responsibility it's not like
he's there's one person that only talks
to the engineering team and manages
print and another person that is
collecting market feedback it's not the
case it's it's it's full stack but full
stack in in a limited scope
definitely now
how do you close the loop so with the
engineering runs full stack pms are
running we have a product
what's happening now from the lenses of
the pm okay so
um
let's try to break down the day of of
pme at talk for instance because now we
have seven pm's it's already running
fast we are hiring more so we can
actually see what everyone are doing and
we have two um two cycles of planning or
two
let's call it two resolutions of
planning first we have the quarterly
plan a quarterly plan is something that
we do in the strategic level
every beginning of every quarter we have
the business goal it's the business
goals of the quarter like we say that
next in the end of next quarter we want
to be with x amount of revenues we want
to be in x amount of clients of a
certain kind solving a certain type of
issues certain use cases
so then we align on the quarterly
strategy then every then we see okay
what are the features we have like an
offsite some big event and we break down
the features or the important
capabilities that we think we need in
order to reach those goals in three
months from now it's not that far away
again this is not waterfall approach we
are not committing on a plan but we just
want to see what we need to work on
in the next couple of months to reach
those goals what is what are the
capabilities we are missing
and what is the order which is like the
two main things that products eventually
is doing defining what we want to build
in the next couple of months and in
which order and every
line item in that list have a unique
priority it's not like everything is
either half important and has not we're
doing it in a unique priority so we know
exactly what comes before what and
that's a very long and difficult
discussion but everyone are coming with
lots of input from the market we does
the research so we can define it
once we define what we're going to work
on then we're breaking it down with the
engineer then the engineering team is
joining us and we're breaking it down
into okay we're gonna we have this
capability let's say
just for example in talk we are adding
an ability to do a workflow within a
workflow
some feature so now we have a product
manager that's leading this it's a very
complex feature that many clients see in
different ways we need to align the
views we need to have some marketing
around it
all of those capabilities form
talking to engineers and get a very good
design to how we're going to build it
today how we're going to
train the business the business side of
it to sell that feature and to make sure
users are using that feature is on that
product manager that is now leading that
product capability so every day that
product manager is waking up and
thinking how am i am going to push in
the next again it's it's it's it's in
quarterly strategy how am i pushing
this for this capability and where does
it stand now what are the blockers what
i'm still missing
what issues i need to solve in order to
to execute it faster and that's kind of
like the day-to-day work of the of the
product managers again the other cycle
is the sprint because the engineering
team is working in agile form
but
we are not the owners of the sprint the
sprint is something that the engineers
are doing in order to manage their work
efficiently and we are helping them do
that but we are not owning this
fantastic
uh i gained so much insight over these
20 minutes and i really appreciate it
but i have i have two last questions
that i have to ask you um not about what
the product management but about your
perspective on product management well
you know you transitioned quite a bit
within the industry from different
positions and now you've taken on really
incredible roles at some of some of
israel's you know proudest companies so
you know why why product management why
doing product management for 10 years
why continuing to do it and and more
companies what is it about product
management that you really love
um
i love solving powder problems
um solving problems was the reason i
became an engineer to begin with
and it was satisfying while
while i was doing it from the technical
side but eventually when you want to
find bigger problems and lead the
solution in a larger scale the product
manager role gives you something
completely bigger the way i see it
again
getting
getting to engineering site is fun i
mean i even do it for time to time but
eventually it's it's so
satisfying to see that you found
a user you found
eventually even in big organization
there are some users on the other side
that you see them using the product and
you see them that
you hear the feedback and you said okay
we had a huge problem we couldn't do
all of that work we had to and now
thanks to your product we can do that
again it's also helpful to be successful
in the business side
but seeing the reactions from the users
when you're
delivering
such product
was the or all of the sound walk
beautiful and if you had to choose a few
words to describe yourself or if i had
to if i had to if i were to ask anybody
that i got to work with you in the last
10 years who who is omer frat
what words come to mind that's a tough
one and
i think one thing i can again compliment
myself about that
i
in many cases i came with product
visions that people did not believe that
were possible
and
delivered eventually
so i think this is what again if i'm
looking for a compliment that would be
that i guess um
finding big enough problems with big
enough vision
um
and and showing that it's possible
very very cool omelet
thank you very very much for these last
20 minutes
really inspiring and um thank you for
taking me through the life cycle of a pm
and and the way of thinking and the the
challenges the sensitivities the
intricacies
of this position the way that you're
interacting with the different you know
groups in the organization and then to
to to build great products together so
thank you very very much and stay safe
and stay healthy and best of luck with
torque sounds like an incredible thank
you so much for your time